so what are typical questions that will
be asked in these interviews and again
here there might be differences firm by
firm but usually the questions are quite
predictable you will be asked to talk
about an instance of your past where you
achieve something that you are really
proud of or you will be asked to talk
about the team conflict that you had
with another person in the past and how
you were able to overcome that conflict
what you actually did to solve it you
might be asked about any specific
element that you have on your CV to
provide a story on how you really
achieved an impact how you really made a
difference to the firm to the
organization that you were a member of